[Música]
fecha importante 22 de mayo del 2022 ese
día los integrantes del congreso de eeuu
que patrocinan proyectos de ley en
competencia para resolver lo relacionado
con el estatus de la isla de puerto rico
y la relación que tiene con la unión
americana presentaron una propuesta
combinada que une elementos a favor de
pasar a hacer un estado plenamente
integrado a la unión americana o la
opción republicana a través de una ley
de autodeterminación el proyecto de ley
dice que el 5 de noviembre del 2023 será
realizado un plebiscito para resolver el
estatus político de puerto rico
escuchemos las palabras de jenniffer
gonzález la comisionada residente que es
miembro de la cámara de representantes
federales que por mandato y ley
representa al estado libre asociado de
puerto rico ante todo el gobierno de
eeuu escuchemos
esto empoderar a la gente de puerto rico
a votar en un proceso democrático y
transparente sobre su futuro
les permitirá saber exactamente las
consecuencias sobre las decisiones que
toman a través de una campaña electoral
y lo que el congreso quiere ofrecer
wow
esto establecerá un mecanismo para
implementar la decisión que refleje el
deseo de la gente de puerto rico hemos
estado debatiendo en nuestra relación
política con eeuu por más de 120 años y
entonces quedan varias preguntas puerto
rico- entonces pasará a ser un estado
pleno de la unión americana pasará a ser
una república o hará una leve
modificación al estatus de estado libre
asociado pero veamos algunos datos
básicos de esta isla que está ubicada en
el caribe puerto rico como lo decía es
un estado libre asociado de estados
unidos- su capital es la ciudad de san
juan la isla cuenta con 3.1 millones de
habitantes el cargo más alto a nivel
político corresponde al del gobernador
de la isla de puerto rico
hagamos también un poco de retrospectiva
pues fue parte del reino de españa entre
1493 y
1898 precisamente el 25 de julio de 1898
tiene lugar la sesión a eeuu al
finalizar la guerra
hispano-estadounidense un momento
histórico en el que es y entrega a eeuu
la soberanía de cuba puerto rico guam y
las filipinas puerto rico pasa a ser
entonces oficialmente un estado libre
asociado de la unión americana el 25 de
julio de
1952 la isla tiene constitución propia
ha realizado varios referendos para que
los ciudadanos se pronuncien sobre el
estatus de este territorio pero no ha
sido vinculante ninguno de ellos la
consulta del 11 de junio de 2017 tampoco
fue vinculante pero sí fue muy diciente
el 97 por ciento votó a favor de la
estatidad el 1.5 por ciento a favor de
la independencia
1.32 por ciento a favor de mantener el
estatus actual
la participación solamente llegó al 22
por ciento de el padrón electoral
habilitado en puerto rico- los
puertorriqueños pueden votar en las
elecciones primarias pero no pueden
votar en las elecciones presidenciales a
menos que estén residiendo en la zona
continental de eeuu en qué condiciones
políticas y sociales se encuentra
entonces la isla de puerto rico para
definir su estatus
en el 2023 que dicen desde eeuu sobre
esta elección que dicen desde san juan
cuáles son las repercusiones de volverse
un estado pleno de estados unidos o de
independizarse y volverse una república
independiente por su cuenta que le
conviene más a la 'isla del encanto'
ubicada en el caribe pues para conversar
sobre ese tema saludamos a jose enrique
meléndez él es representante a la cámara
por el partido nuevo progresista él se
encuentra en la ciudad de guaynabo y
desde san juan la capital de puerto rico
se conecta a adrián gonzález él es
secretario de organización del partido
independentista les recuerdo que ustedes
también hacen parte de esta conversación
pueden dejar todas sus preguntas y sus
comentarios en nuestras redes sociales
estamos en twitter estamos en instagram
en facebook en donde no se encuentran
como france24
arroba xanthi logo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 dejen todos sus
comentarios en youtube pueden seguir
también nuestra señal en streaming y
aprovecho para saludar a las personas
que nos escuchan a través de nuestro
podcast los invito para que nos escuchen
en las diferentes plataformas
ya está disponible nuestro contenido el
podcast spotify deezer y tuning
bueno pues le doy la bienvenida entonces
a nuestros invitados y paso a nuestro
punto de partida la primera pregunta
para conocer opiniones sobre este tema
le doy la bienvenida entonces a jose
enrique meléndez y punto de partida josé
enrique primero que todo bienvenido al
programa gracias por estar con nosotros
y debe puerto rico- entonces realizar
este referendo en el 2023 sí o no y en
ese caso qué opción es la mejor desde su
punto de vista para puerto rico- ser un
estado seguir siendo un estado libre
asociado o una república independiente
muchas gracias por invitarme a tu
programa de salud o también
principalmente puerto rico tienen
problemas graves que tiene que terminar
de una vez por todas con el asunto
estatus colonial tenemos que dejar de
ser colonia para dejar es el colon de
colonia hay que precisamente consultar
al pueblo de opciones que desee
colonicen que rompan el tipo de economía
que puerto rico pueda tener un gobierno
totalmente propio y que pueda participar
luego así por el caso de un gobierno
completo que sabe en el al día de hoy
puerto rico no es estado no es libre y
tampoco me asociado así que el 5 de
noviembre del 23 y una propuesta de una
consulta que podría resolver esto de una
manera bien importante vinculante lo que
pueblo decida es lo que se va a escoger
lo que se va a ejecutar sí y ahora
saludo adrián gonzález en la ciudad de
san juan bienvenido a adrián su opinión
debe puerto rico entonces realizar si o
no este referendo y en ese escenario
cuál será la mejor opción para este
territorio
mira en primer lugar muchos saludos a ti
al compañero del panel y a todas las
personas que nos están viendo y
escuchando y mira este proyecto que está
ante la consideración del congreso de
los eeuu creo que es un paso importante
como decía el representante puerto rico
no es mi estado ni es libre ni es
asociado a la definición jurídica de
puerto rico es un territorio no
incorporado a los eeuu y el nombre de
estado libre asociado es un nombre que
se dispuso en 1950 en 1950 exactamente y
por el congreso de los eeuu para dar un
matiz de democracia y arrojar ver a
despejar perdón cualquier insinuación
sobre que eeuu en plena guerra fría
tenía una colonia en el caribe cuando
estaba
luchando por así decirlo en contra de
los países europeos posguerra por las
colonias que tengas en áfrica y
precisamente en el caribe así que todo
esto del 52 fue simplemente un max viaje
a la colonia que es hemos sido desde
españa y retomando el tema de este
proyecto en el congreso como bien indica
este en la introducción aquí han habido
muchas consultas y en todas ha sido una
conversación entre los puertorriqueños
que ha faltado en esa mesa
una persona muy importante una figura
muy importante que era el congreso de
los eeuu lo más cerca que estuvimos a un
plebiscito o consulta
con un mandato verdad del congreso o con
participación del congreso fue en el 89
así que 30 años después el hecho de que
se esté moviendo el tema del estatus de
puerto rico para movernos hacia un lado
o hacia el otro tiene que verse con
buenos ojos así no sea el 5 de noviembre
del 2023 y un elemento muy importante
destacó de esta consulta es que dejaría
afuera la opción de estado libre
asociado como una opción para salir del
problema y es que efectivamente el
problema no puede ser una solución al
problema así que tal como está redactado
este proyecto contempla o anexarse a los
eeuu con vestimenta 251 o la soberanía a
través ya sea de la libre asociación con
algunas islas del pacífico o la
independencia absoluta
jose enrique y adrián quiero que hagamos
un panorama entre ustedes dos para la
audiencia de france 24 sobre cómo está
la situación en puerto rico para
entender si esto es un momento
coyuntural de descontento social por las
políticas que ha tenido eeuu o si
simplemente es un movimiento y un sentir
de los puertorriqueños que ha ido
creciendo a lo largo de los años sobre
una necesidad como identidad como nación
o como estado como se le quiera llamar
de tener un estatus completamente
definido y hemos visto que la isla tiene
muchas dificultades con su deuda ha
tenido problemas después del paso de
varios huracanes la pandemia de kobe 19
también impactó con fuerza en esta isla
como se encuentra puerto rico a nivel
económico a nivel político y a nivel
social comienzo entonces con jose
enrique a la situación económica de la
isla siente siempre ha sido un problema
porque puerto rico como territorio no
incorporado todo ha subido como
mencionaba adrián ciertamente no en
cuenta con herramientas necesarias para
desarrollar una economía próspera porque
al no ser estado pues no necesariamente
este podemos hacer las mismas
participaciones en congresos para buscar
la forma de atender los asuntos
domésticos desde el congreso con más
recursos pero tampoco somos una
república independiente que pudiéramos
estar entonces ha sido tratados con
distintos países para poder lograr que
conseguir los lo mejor que nos convenga
en términos de
tratados de comercio y participación
para grabaciones internacionales por lo
tanto por público estar metido
actualmente en el medio de una paella
gigante verdad desde los mercados
internacionales pero no tener no tenemos
ninguna víctima tipo de participación en
ese poso y eso lo que ha provocado es
que el puerto vengo de tiempo en tiempo
y esto hay que reconocerlo los los
partidos que han gobernado por torrico
mi partido y por el principio de otro
partido opositor bloqueando lo que
apostó por delante hacer fue buscar la
forma de mover la economía pero lo
hicieron de una manera y hay que
reconocerlo que no necesariamente es la
correcta tratamos cortar dónde vivir
sin serlo porque es importante bueno
porque para poder tratar de hacerlo usar
la tarjeta de crédito básicamente
entonces endeudaron a puerto rico
demasiado puerto rico tiene un gigante y
ya con eso supongo que congreso
impusiera a siete personas que no son
electos por el pueblo de puerto rico y
que tampoco son en ninguna elección
simplemente seleccionado por el
presidente de los eeuu para que vengan
aquí donde poner algún tipo de verdad en
términos fiscales y que ellos hagan lo
que quieran hacer y de ello en tanto el
poder que se le dio que han intervenido
básicamente en todas las etapas sociales
de nuestra y adrián sus impresiones
sobre este tema panorama general de la
isla
mira el panorama general de la isla yo
creo que es muy distinto a lo que fue
quizás hace incluso cinco años pues no
decir hace 20 30 40 50 años y es que
precisamente se ha visto se ha venido
viendo el deterioro de lo que es de lo
que fue una economía es artificial
sustentada en ni nada simplemente en
endeudamiento en el consumo de edad no
en producción y además
cuando llegamos al tope del
endeudamiento y entré a la junta de
control fiscal que son estas siete
personas que se nombraba el
representante la economía de puerto rico
y los problemas sociales se han
agudizado muchísimo y tanto a las
generaciones que vieron el progreso del
estado libre asociado y el deterioro
como las generaciones nuevas que sólo
han vivido el deterioro están
conscientes que la raíz de los problemas
que estamos viendo en términos de por
ejemplo como mencionaste la recuperación
después de un huracán el manejo de una
pandemia el desarrollo económico que no
existe las medidas de austeridad
impuestas desde washington que encarecen
todos los servicios esenciales como la
luz y el agua encarece en la universidad
pública que ahora mismo es tres veces lo
que costaba hace cinco años desde antes
justo antes de que existiera la junta de
control fiscal
y muchísimos otros ejemplos que hacen de
puerto rico un país inhabitable y más
allá de lo que es la identidad no
nacional creo que
la mayoría de los puertorriqueños y las
estadísticas están ahí del 2010 al 2020
sufrimos una merma poblacional de medio
millón de habitantes eso quiere decir
que las circunstancias en la isla
hicieron que 50 mil personas se fueran
de puerto rico- cada año -soy buscando
mejores oportunidades porque simplemente
el territorio no se las proveyó lari son
personas que con el estatus que tiene
puerto rico pueden irse a eeuu
continental hay que aclararse lo a los
televidentes porque tienen precisamente
pasaporte estadounidense les permite
trabajar y estudiar allí vivir en eeuu
como cualquier ciudadano y estando allí
si pueden ejercer su derecho al voto en
las elecciones presidenciales
teniendo claro estas dificultades en el
panorama económico político y social que
tiene un puerto rico pasó al lado social
adrián a preguntarle en las calles de
las ciudades puertorriqueñas en las
calles de san juan qué percepción tienen
los habitantes cómo están las cargas
equilibradas a favor de volverse un
estado incorporarse por completo
independizarse en mantenerse como están
llevando esta carga y este problema por
quién sabe cuántos años más cuál es el
sentir de la gente en la calle sobre
este referendo y sobre esta decisión
y mira como como mencionaba
anteriormente hay una noción general de
que sí sí tiene que haber un cambio y el
cambio verdad y cuál va a ser esa vía el
final es lo que todavía hay que refinar
hace falta todavía muchísimo educación
en cuanto al tema de lo que significaría
un proceso de autodeterminación y lass
en cuál sería la meta o cuál sería el
punto culminante de ese proceso pero lo
que sí te puedo garantizar es que nadie
absolutamente nadie está conforme con
convivir en un territorio no incorporado
y muy conscientes de las limitaciones de
los retos que implica el vivir como
hemos estado viviendo por los últimos 60
años pero particularmente y de forma muy
muy especial los últimos 15 años han
sido años de crisis que el desempleo
el alto costo de la vida ha hecho que
cada vez más personas y sobre todo las
nuevas generaciones se estén generando
un cambio no te puedo decir que ha
habido un crecimiento muy importante
hacia la integración independentismo en
no hablar de la independencia hoy no es
lo mismo que hablar de la independencia
hace 25 o 30 años o 15 ó 10 creo creo
que es por ahí se van perfilando las
cosas y es que todas las crisis les
llaman a la polarización y hay un gran
sector que piensa que la gran solución
es convertirnos en el estado 51 y entrar
en una es un alivio temporero y hay un
gran sector que piensa que debemos en
vez de integrarnos a los eeuu
integrarnos al mundo pero de la forma
que estamos enajenado ahora ciertamente
no podemos continuar
y le doy la palabra entonces a jose
enrique uno pensaría por lo menos desde
la perspectiva latinoamericana que tener
una buena y estrecha relación con eeuu
va a ser beneficioso dependiendo del
punto de vista que uno lo pueda mirar
podría ser beneficioso y la relación que
tiene puerto rico con washington es más
que una relación estrecha y beneficiosa
que puede decir uno del balance de esta
relación entre estos dos territorios que
le deja positivo eeuu a puerto rico
hasta ahora y que le reclama puerto rico
eeuu a lo largo de estos años era bien
importante no sólo en puerto rico
no solamente es recibimos de los eeuu
somos ciudadanos por nacimientos
ciudadanos de con esta opción por
nacimiento y yo creo que eso parte es
importante por eso que tenemos la
movilidad tan fácil entre puerto rico y
cualquiera conectado de importante y un
dato que es básica significativo hay
cerca de 67 millones de cuerpos pequeños
que están ya viviendo en los estados
unidos así que yo creo que es importante
verdad que la gente entienda que hay más
puertorriqueños fuera de puerto rico
pidiendo a los estados que así que
habiendo dicho eso los puertorriqueños
hemos estado aportando al desarrollo
económico otros estados y muchas muchas
áreas lo que tenemos y los
puertorriqueños que obviamente
alternando hasta el espacio de siete
instituciones sociales internacional
hemos tenido tenemos también tenemos
tanto una puertorriqueña en el la corte
suprema de eeuu menciones por mayor así
que desde ese perspectiva puerto rico
participa verdad aunque no directamente
en toda la internet comúnmente integrado
porque no funciona para efectos
prácticos para él como una como un
estado típico del estado somos lo que
les falta puerto rico en esta etapa es
precisamente igualdad de participación
en todos los programas sociales
federales pero más importante ahonda la
igualdad en el proceso de tomar las
decisiones porque puerto rico al día de
hoy tienen una comisionada residente que
evidentemente puede brindar muchísimo y
hacer todo más vamos a ver que lo ha
hecho y ha sido bastante pero sin
embargo cuando llegue el momento de
decidir es básicamente le dicen siéntese
correcto una esquina porque la verdad
que esto tiene un poco para poder
entonces
influenciar con su voto la legislación
que se apoye dentro de el recolector y
ccoo ha sido que en puerto rico en
pequeños se ha ido
expresando el libremente a favor de
rentabilidad y no solamente en el
plebiscito del 17 cuando hubo una
abstención de la oposición política pero
también en la pasada elección en el 2020
hubo también una consulta de estatus y
letalidad una mayoría absoluta
definitivamente de el resultado en esa
en esa exitosa consulta que así sea con
una participación de cerca del 80% de
los puertorriqueños así que porque yo
pero es importante que miremos el
contexto y si esté ahí hay que educar y
yo creo que en ese ejercicio todos los
partidos porque como puerto rico porque
creemos obviamente el expedida el pp
cree también en otra solución que tienen
que hacer lo importante es que rompamos
a las personas que finalmente
créeme que debes seguir ya que eso
ciertamente no es una solución de futuro
bueno entonces hagamos esa labor jose
enrique y comienzo entonces
preguntándole cómo sería un puerto rico
siendo estado plenamente incorporada
eeuu cómo cambiaría entonces
políticamente y la vida de los
puertorriqueños a que podrían tener
acceso luego entonces le pregunto adrián
cómo sería una república independiente
de puerto rico
pero es importante que la gente entienda
por torrico como estado tendría verdad
más poder que 23 estados y esa parte es
importante en cualquier población que en
muchos otros estados y más de la mitad
de los estados pero estaba sumamente
representación corrección e sería
bastante amplia y no solamente eso
podríamos ser y eso es lo que siempre se
ha cortado de cristal puerto rico puede
ser el representante hispano y
latinoamericano dentro del gobierno de
los eeuu en términos de la vida social
pero puertorriqueño evidentemente por
por tipo tendría más recursos para poder
entonces evitar verdad reducir así las
contribuciones locales para poder paliar
este cual obviamente el bolsillo del
cuerpo riqueza pero más importante aún
tendría obviamente participación en
todos los programas sociales y
obviamente la la seguridad lo que le
llaman en el investment por eso de que
por fin ya a puerto rico no ha resuelto
finalmente su prueba de tabucchi y que
cualquier inversionista compañía verdad
que de seguir vertir es por correcto
sabe que va a contar con una bandera
donde toda opción de manera permanente
en puerto rico y yo creo que eso
era la riqueza que es necesaria para
demostrar el talento
rico que se ha estado yendo hacia el
ecuador tristemente claro y adrián como
sería entonces la otra cara de la moneda
como sería un puerto rico independiente
un puerto rico que le extiendo un poco
más la pregunta cómo sería esa
integración de este nuevo país a la
realidad latinoamericana ya la realidad
mundial
y yo creo que en ese panorama
tenemos muchos pasos adelantados y no lo
digo yo como independentista o como
puertorriqueño yo creo que todas las
personas que no están bien de
latinoamérica es perciben a puerto 5
como un país y es porque nuestra
identidad es tan fuerte que muchas
personas no se imaginan que puerto rico
tiene un vínculo tan estrecho con los
eeuu porque somos eso una nación
latinoamericana y caribeña
y ese es uno de los grandes obstáculos
para que nos finalmente en todo caso que
su día es si se aspirar a convertirse en
un estado 51 como eso no depende de
nosotros depende completamente del
congreso de eeuu no va a haber unos
estados unidos- plurinacionales así que
dicho eso lo más importante de un puerto
rico soberano e independiente que son
las herramientas que tendría por ejemplo
para el repago de la deuda bajó bajó la
calidad bajo la anexión como un estado
de la unión americana posiblemente nos
quedemos con la junta como mecanismo de
transición y siga siendo el congreso
que maneja en los fondos públicos de la
isla un puerto rico soberano tendría las
herramientas que han tenido todos los
países del mundo para manejar por
ejemplo sus de sus deudas públicas y ni
hablar de las herramientas de desarrollo
económico la posibilidad de llegar a
acuerdos con otros países de los cuales
ahora estamos completamente impedidos y
cuando hablo de acuerdo no es solamente
comprar petróleo barato es por ejemplo
después de un huracán de quien recibimos
ayuda todo eso está completamente
controlado con los eeuu les podemos
estar días hablando de la de lo que son
los créditos versus las posibilidades de
un país soberano e independiente de
tener un desarrollo económico de que la
gente no se vaya del país yo creo que
somos el único país de latinoamérica y
quizás así se debe al libre tránsito que
hay que tienen más personas afuera 7
millones de puertorriqueños fuera de
puerto rico y 3 millones en la isla eso
no es un país con un desarrollo
económico y si nos convertimos en un
estado de la unión la única diferencia
que va a haber es que misisipí va a
dejar de ser esta o más y va a
convertirse en puerto rico en el estado
más pobre porque de la misma lista que
desglosó el representante no se
desprende nada de desarrollo económico
sino al contrario ayudas sociales ayudas
sociales ayudas sociales y si las
necesitamos pero estás yo necesitamos no
necesitaremos ayuda social que
necesitamos mucha ayuda sociales porque
hay mucha pobreza en la isla pero la
idea que no haya tanta pobreza en la
isla claro adrián desde la perspectiva
en san juan en cómo se percibe entonces
en la opinión de washington que dice
eeuu frente a esto está dispuesto a
perder a que una de las posibilidades es
tener que dejar ir a este territorio en
el caribe o está dando una batalla por
mantenerlo o se está haciendo una
campaña en la parte continental para que
se incorpore como un estado más cuál es
la visión de washington
yo creo que hay distintas versiones y
divisiones hay un sector progresista en
eeuu que erróneamente piensa que
convertir a los puertorriqueños en el
estado 51 sería hacernos un gran favor y
a darnos igualdad con los otros
ciudadanos americanos y esa es una
visión incluso hasta casi racista porque
que como que no podemos aspirar a otras
cosas y aspiramos a hacer 100 por ciento
puertorriqueños somos menos de la
plenitud sería alcanzada siendo
americano eso no va a pasar y en una
visión es rap por otra parte los
intereses de eeuu en puerto rico-
dejaron de ser los mismos hace casi 20
años en eeuu cerró prácticamente todas
sus bases militares en puerto rico en el
2003 y de ahí de ese momento en adelante
es que el tema del estatus de la isla ha
tenido un progreso bastante rápido
porque claro obviamente mientras
estuvieron mientras eeuu
tenía una visión de altamente
militarizadas de su gobierno
precisamente por la primera por la
segunda por corea por prisión etcétera
la posición geopolítica de puerto rico
en el caribe protegiendo al canal de
panamá también
era privilegiadísima y si era éramos la
joya de la corona en términos
geopolíticos pero eso ya no existe
nosotros no representamos para eeuu una
es una inyección económica importante se
les que les haga en verdad que les
fuerce a dejar este territorio aquí
porque significa algo para su economía
al contrario así que yo creo que las
condiciones tanto en puerto rico como en
eeuu son más que jonas para seguir dando
esos pasos hacia la descolonización
jose enrique le doy la palabra sobre
este tema su opinión eeuu podrá dejar ir
este territorio si el referendo así lo
dice si la votación de los ciudadanos
así lo indica o se está haciendo alguna
campaña un movimiento o por lo menos
instando o para tratar de ofrecerle algo
a puerto rico atractivo para que se
sigan siendo parte de la unión americana
mira yo creo que aquí la parte más
importante delante no te ofrecimiento
que por primera vez del congreso a los
eeuu está trabajando un proyecto
en si finalmente la votación se da el
resultado de explotación es vinculante y
aquí en puerto rico había de hecho la
posición política
interesantemente no necesariamente la
posición independentista porque la
posición independiente siempre ciudad
monterrey está contento por la posición
del statu quo lo que creen que esta
visión siempre han dicho que eeuu nunca
habría de ofrecer una recta vida como
una alternativa entonces cuando se trae
este proyecto porque toda la cámara
resultante ocho personas que es la que
estamos discutiendo en este momento en
el congreso pues si hay no solamente la
alternativa de rentabilidad se convierte
en una posibilidad real sino que también
se hace tanto ejecutable así que en
términos de la oferta que puede estar
dando el gobierno de los eeuu y el color
puerto rico se encuentra la
incorporación definitiva con una
transición de apenas un año para que el
puerto rico tenga todos los derechos
igual y por cualquiera de los cinco
estados
así que de la misma forma aplica hay que
hacerlo de esa forma
en caso de que puerto rico se convierta
y decidamos la repubblica asociada o por
una república totalmente independiente
sería el resultado totalmente
autorizable así que el gobierno de los
estados se siente había dispuesto según
está presentado en este proyecto es
precisamente el cual se aprueba salió
del comité era light está pendiente de
votación en la cámara en el pleno pero
es si está planteada la posibilidad de
una unión permanente a través del estado
o de una separación permanente a través
de dos vías independencia así que
cuál es la que
tiene que aceptar según el proyecto por
la que el poleo porque está claro la
elección a través del voto por parte de
los puertorriqueños llama mucho la
atención josé enrique que estemos en
pleno año 2022 y estemos hablando de
procesos de descolonización
en nuestro continente en américa
esto no puede generar de pronto un
efecto bola de nieve con otros
territorios que hay sobre todo en el
caribe porque también está por ejemplo
las islas vírgenes de estados unidos o
está la isla de guam en el pacífico
hay algunos territorios franceses
británicos veíamos hace un par de meses
a barbados
desmarcándose de la mancomunidad
británica y volviéndose una república
independiente esto se está generando ese
sentimiento de la necesidad de
independencia de estos territorios de
ultramar en el caribe como lo ve usted
fíjate yo creo que es una gran pregunta
la que tú has que en realidad sí y ahí
lo que creemos realmente en la lucha y
en la actualización de la pólvora la
verdad pues tenemos que entender que tú
y claro tienen que darse a veces se da
más tarde que temprano andar mucho con
tarde le gustaría pero la vida del caso
es que los pueblos necesitan tener la
oportunidad escoger cuál va a ser su
futuro definitivo no pueden estar en ese
statu quo de hecho en el caso de las
islas vírgenes tienen su relación
particular y no veo muchos movimientos
en este papá verdad este sobre interés
en el estado pero si lo veo y por
ejemplo en el turno de ciudad juan hay
una particularidad donde precisamente el
one y samoa americana han estado
precisamente llevando casos el tribunal
superior con estados unidos buscando
precisamente no solamente lograr la
ciudadanía de los estados unidos sino
lograr mejores condiciones para este
para sus ciudadanos así que si hay algún
tipo de movimiento en términos de lo que
están bien pendiente lo que pueda
ocurrir en puerto rico para ellos
precisamente personas de manera pudiendo
esos de su propio gran a cruzar el
módulo de puerto rico de hecho una de
las cosas que queremos hacer laica
porque queremos hacer este proceso de
manera adecuada es que en el modelo que
se use para acosar a puerto rico sea
modelo que pueda ser ejemplo para
cualquier otra otra jurisdicción casas
que puedan ser aplicado en otros en
otros estados que están buscando ese
mismo futuro adrián algo que me llama la
atención es que también al interior de
puerto rico y sobre todo últimas semanas
y meses ha habido también un sentimiento
por parte de los ciudadanos y también un
poco a nivel político y apostándole a la
reunificación de puerto rico con españa
algo que puede sonar muy loco pero hay
movimientos que lo están apostando así
españa no se ha pronunciado al respecto
pero el ejemplo que pone en la figura
que ponen es que pueda ser una comunidad
autónoma como es por ejemplo canarias
con un estatuto de autonomía este
escenario es completamente inviable como
lo ve usted
mira realmente ese sí que es un grupo
muy pequeño eso yo lo he visto en las
redes sociales pero no hay tal cosa como
un movimiento para la reunificación con
españa además si es una rémora seguir
siendo colonia de eeuu que lo somos
desde el siglo 19 creo que insistir en
la reunificación con españa sería
retroceder casi 600 años en la historia
y ningún país ningún pueblo ha estado
diseñado para hacer colonia
perpetuamente al contrario la historia
de los pueblos es la liberación y eso yo
hasta en la biblia se menciona y creo
que por ahí vamos encaminados todos los
países y tras este un punto muy
importante el caribe tiene una
particularidad es que es donde más
territorios quieran dominados por algún
tipo de país sobre otros mencionaste las
islas vírgenes americanas pero holanda
tiene las antillas holandesas hay
departamentos de ultramar de francia
y creo que en el siglo 21 en pleno 2022
el que se esté hablando cada vez más de
la necesidad de estos territorios de
adquirir su propio estatus como países
vamos en la dirección correcta porque se
habla del multilateralismo de
regionalización de políticas de
interdependencia sin embargo hacemos
territorios que estamos cada vez más
aislados de esas políticas de
cooperación internacional precisamente
por otros países que nos imponen un
gobierno desde afuera y que el
colonialismo puro y duro como lo fue
desde que los españoles llegaron a
américa claro si puede sonar un poco
absurdo esto de la reunificación que en
españa pero había que ponerlo sobre la
mesa porque el aro no ha sentido un
grupo de personas en puerto rico que lo
ven como algo viable y le apuestan a eso
y también es válido traerlo acá a la
mesa del debate ya me quedan pocos
minutos para terminar en esta
conversación este análisis con jose
enrique con adrián entonces pues
llegamos a las conclusiones sobre lo que
va a suceder qué camino va a tomar esta
es la que camino va a tomar puerto rico
a raíz de este referendo va a pasar esta
propuesta se va a llevar a cabo este
referendo va a haber una independencia
va a haber una incorporación el
escenario así no tengamos bola de
cristal para saber el futuro josé
enrique comienzo con usted mira la
verdad que se está haciendo todo lo
posible para lograr que este puesto su
prueba pero independientemente el
posición de o no porque no tiene que ser
realice con bien las cosas se dan o no
se dan pero me parece a mí que llamativo
y hay importante destacar el el
contenido del proceso yo creo que el
hecho de que este proceso ya se ha
realizado y se aprobó un comité podría
aprobarse en el mes de septiembre en la
cámara de representantes yo no estoy tan
seguro y no sabemos si finalmente es el
senado tenga tiempo para poder verle un
estado estable
digamos que no suceda por lo menos
sienta las bases me parece a mí para un
para que se pueda partir un punto de
partida para el próximo por el proceso
de trato para una cámara de
representantes- ilustrado a futuro
porque de todas formas aunque yo creo
que hay todavía para probar lo creo en
este proyecto al ser vinculante y
excluyendo verdad lo que es el problema
que tiene puerto rico le da unas
opciones que son preciosas por corregir
las oportunidades en que no se vende
prisión adrián un minuto para su
conclusión para el cierre del programa
que va a suceder con la isla del encanto
yo mira desde el punto de vista
independentista nosotros llevamos a una
lucha que empezó contra españa en 1868
nunca hemos claudicado y creo que ahora
se están viendo los frutos como te decía
hace un momento no es lo mismo hablar
desde la independencia de puerto rico
hoy en el 2022 que hace pocos años los
resultados de las elecciones del 2020 ha
sido demostrar que el partido
independentista obtuvo 2% en las
elecciones del 2016 y en las elecciones
2010 20 obtuvo un 14% pero que esos son
un 14 por ciento de seis candidatos
apenas la mitad de lo que obtuvo el
gobernador electo que tuvo fue electo
con 30%
y creo que esos son mensajes importantes
que están llegando a washington y a la
comunidad internacional sobre lo que los
puertorriqueños queremos y en la medida
que aquí se siga moviendo el tema pues
claro que se ejerció una presión sobre
el congreso pues habían josé enrique les
agradezco mucho por habernos explicado
sobre la realidad política de esta isla
importante muy conectada con américa
latina' por supuesto y lo que puede
venir para este territorio en los
próximos meses
porque no en el 2023 y esta propuesta
finalmente pues se lleva a cabo les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
ustedes también muchas gracias por la
sintonía sigan con france24
[Música]